[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
risiken einen schönen samstagabend ihnen
allen in den nächsten 20 minuten die
wichtigsten nachrichten ab jetzt ja auch
mal mit einer täglichen dosis olympia
heute wieder mit christina und nun
voller freude über silber guten abend
und das haben wir heute unter anderem
für sie vorbereitet
ukraine krise nach der
machtdemonstration von russland und
china steigt die anspannung im westen
comecon infektionen bei babys immer mehr
säuglinge müssen mit corona ins
krankenhaus
und erste medaille bei olympia
skispringerinnen katharina althaus
verpasst knapp den sieg und gewinnt
silber in peking
der konflikt zwischen russland der
ukraine und dem westen bleibt enorm
angespannt während russische kampfjets
nach belarus verlegt wurden landeten
heute die ersten von rund 2000 us
soldaten zur verstärkung in europa
zusätzlichen zündstoff liefert das
mächtige china dass russland gestern
partnerschaft und unterstützung zusagte
die kriegsangst bleibt groß besonders
auf ukrainischer seite die weiter
deutsche unterstützung einfordert
alexandra vacano
die ukrainische armee möchte zeigen was
sie hat und was sie kann und lädt
internationale journalisten zum
pressetermin nach pripjat in die nähe
von tschernobyl
doch das land möchte mehr waffen und
zwar ganz offiziell von deutschland
flugabwehrraketen systeme munition anti
drohnen gewähre während die
bundesregierung waffenlieferungen
ablehnt kann sich die opposition in
berlin unterstützung im bereich der
defensivwaffen vorstellen
das sind alle systeme die der aufklärung
dienen und die beispielsweise dazu
dienen können das panzer sich frei
bewegen können und alles was man sich an
waffensystemen dafür vorstellen kann
gehört zur palette dessen was der westen
zur verfügung stellen kann derweil sucht
russlands präsident putin unterstützung
und bekommt sie von china
schulterschluss gestern in peking zu
beginn der olympischen spiele es war für
wladimir putin jetzt ein besonders
günstiger zeitpunkt sich auch mit
treffen in china weil er selber mit der
ukraine krise unter druck steht und eben
dem westen damit demonstrieren wollte
dass er nicht isoliert ist international
und da bekam er eben aus china
ausbildung wichtige rückendeckung
denn 1 schweißt moskau und peking
zusammen der gemeinsame kontrahent usa
schickten nun erste verstärkung truppen
nach polen und wie hier nach wiesbaden
während russland kampfjets nach belarus
nahe der polnischen grenze verlegt die
ukraine krise zwinge deutschland die
abhängigkeit vom russischen gas mit rund
50 prozent zu verringern so
wirtschaftsminister habeck nord stream
zwei verschärfe die lage noch
wir müssen hier handeln und uns besser
absichern tun wir das nicht werden wir
zum spielball für bundeskanzler scholz
wird der konflikt in der ukraine sicher
das thema beim antrittsbesuch am montag
in washington
der bundeswirtschaftsminister will also
die abhängigkeit vom russischen gas
verringern wie dringend brauchen wir die
lieferungen aus russland und welche
alternativen gibt es infos dazu finden
sie in unserer zdf heute app und wir
schauen jetzt auch die korona zahlen die
weiter stark steigen und dabei wohl
unvollständig sind weil viele
gesundheitsämter und testeinrichtungen
am limit arbeiten
dem robert koch institut wurden 217 1815
neuinfektionen binnen eines tages
gemeldet das sind 28
1649 mehr als vor einer woche
172 todesfälle kamen dazu die sieben
tage incidents liegt auf dem neuen
höchstwert von
also die coronaviren grassieren weiter
bei uns und zur gruppe der komplett
ungeschützten gehören auch babys die
sich durch die omikron welle auch immer
häufiger infizieren meistens bleibt es
relativ harmlos trotzdem gibt es sorgen
vor möglichen spätfolgen mehr von jan
frederik fischer aus stuttgart
diagnose krone infektion das virus hat
bei dennis fieber ausgelöst die
temperatur klettert auf 39 grad zur
vorsicht wird das baby im klinikum
stuttgart aufgenommen der schock bei der
mutter ist groß
man denkt sich natürlich erstmal
saugefährlich
erst knapp über einen monat alt ja wenn
man weiß es einfach viele emotionen dann
es ist kein einzelfall allein in den
letzten drei wochen kam hier 50
infizierte kleinkinder auf die station
fast so viele wie in der gesamten del
tabelle doch nicht alle sind nur wegen
corona hier oft wird das virus zufällig
bei untersuchungen entdeckt die welle
hat die jüngste altersgruppe voll
erreicht
das liegt daran dass einerseits viel
mehr kinder eine infektion mit nach
hause bringen weil früher ausbrüche in
schulen und kitas meist auf zwei bis
drei kinder begrenzt waren und weil
omikron so ansteckend ist ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass in der familie
die infektion an einen säugling
weitergegeben ist bei omikron deutlich
höher die verläufe sind bei den jüngeren
meist sehr mild omikron sei laut
experten nicht gefährlicher die meisten
müssten nur ein bis zwei nächte im
krankenhaus verbringen doch die sorgen
sie bleiben denn was ist mit den
spätfolgen die kleinkinder bekommen sehr
selten longo mit die jugendlichen können
häufiger lankowitz bekommen zum glück
aber auch nicht so häufig wie die
erwachsenen auch das sehr seltene pimps
syndrom eine schwere entzündungsreaktion
trete bei den kleinsten bisher kaum auf
genau daten für die mikrowelle fehlen
aber noch dennis hat sich inzwischen
schnell erholt er darf nach einer nacht
nach hause
fachkräfte dringend gesucht das gilt für
immer mehr unternehmen im dezember
fehlten nach berechnungen des instituts
der deutschen wirtschaft
465.000 fachkräfte und doppelt so viele
wie zu beginn des jahres die lücken
füllen sollen auch mehr qualifizierte
bewerber aus dem ausland sagt
wirtschaftsminister habeck dafür müssten
aber bürokratische hindernisse abgebaut
werden nach den missbrauchsskandalen in
der katholischen kirche gibt es großen
reformdruck damit beschäftigt sich der
sogenannte synodale weg in frankfurt das
gremium hat sich jetzt für änderungen
bei der katholischen sexualmoral
ausgesprochen ein zentraler punkt die
neubewertung von homosexualität in einem
papier das die bischöfe und laien
befürworten heißt es
gleichgeschlechtliche sexualität sei
keine sünde auch die empfängnisverhütung
soll der papst nach dem willen der
synode zu lassen
frankreich steckt mitten im wahlkampf
der amtierende präsident mag darf auf
eine zweite amtszeit hoffen er gilt als
favorit auch wenn er seine kandidatur
offiziell noch nicht angemeldet hat aber
fast ein drittel der franzosen will nach
umfragen im april ultrarechts wählen
diese stimmen hat bei den letzten wahlen
marine le pen eingesammelt aber diesmal
hat sie konkurrenz im rechten lager dazu
thomas walde aus paris
extremen rechten in den franzosen marine
le pen und ihre partei wegen ihrer
positionen heute rief die
präsidentschaftskandidatin zum
offiziellen wahlkampfauftakt nach ras
ich will den franzosen ihr land zurück
geben ich will ihnen ihre sicherheit
wieder geben ihr geld die früchte ihrer
arbeit
einen eu-austritt frankreichs fordert le
pen nicht mehr um auch für weniger
radikale wählbar zu sein das hat eine
flanke geöffnet nein zum rassismus
begleitet von protesten traf sich le
pens konkurrent der wegen hetze
verurteilte eriks im uhr heute mit
anhängern mit radikaleren tönen
versuchte im urlaub n zu übertreffen
wir hätten die kaufkraft der franzosen
in dem wir die finanzierung der
einwanderung auf unsere kosten beenden
wir müssen aufhören in eure leere
taschen zu greifen um die ganze welt zu
ernähren
solche töne haben folgen viele
frankreich weniger europa fahnen auch
bei den konservativen
sie versuchen sich mit deutlichen
ansagen vor allem zur inneren sicherheit
nach ganz rechts und angreifbar zu
machen
[Applaus]
ich jage die clan chefs die gauner die
dealer die verbrecher die hassprediger
sie werde ich behelligen und ihnen die
bürgerrechte streitig machen ich rücke
mit dem dampfstrahler an dem kärcher
emanuel makro unterscheidet sich mit
pro-europäischen aussagen und fordert
gleichzeitig grenzen stärker zu sichern
auch um den rechten angriffsfläche zu
nehmen denn deren töne prägen durchaus
das politische klima in frankreich
früher passte zwischen dem ehemaligen
us-vizepräsidenten mike pence und
ex-präsident trump kein blatt papier
jetzt attackiert pence trump zum ersten
mal öffentlich pence sagte er habe nach
dem wahlsieg der demokraten nicht das
recht gehabt die wahl zu kippen so wie
es trump verlangt habe kritisierte damit
auch die stimmung des kapitals durch
radikale trump anhänger im januar vor
einem jahr
durch lawinen sind in österreich seit
gestern neun menschen ums leben gekommen
viele verunglückte waren außerhalb der
präparierten pisten unterwegs im
grenzgebiet zur schweiz nahe spitz
wurden gestern fünf schweden und ein
bergführer von einer 400 meter breiten
lawine mitgerissen ein mann überlebte in
schmieren bei innsbruck wurden fünf
teilnehmer einer skitourengruppe
verschüttete ein mann starb
drei lange monate hat der vulkan auf la
palma die menschen in atem gehalten
angsteinflößende und gewaltige
lavaströme zerstörten mehr als 1000
häuser walzen sich unaufhaltsam durch
gärten über straßen und zum teil bis ins
meer das biest nannten die menschen den
vulkan der schließlich kurz vor
weihnachten zur ruhe kam aber ruhe
finden die einwohner noch lange nicht
christel haas
meter hoch ist die lava wand die hier
entstanden ist und sich quer durch diese
ortschaft gefügt hat die gewaltigen
gesteinsmassen werden jetzt teilweise
abgetragen eine neue straße gebaut
der mann der gerade mit seinem lastwagen
ankommt ist kein bauarbeiter er bringt
mobiliar für sein restaurant
ich bringe die hähnchen vater rhein mit
mein hähnchen geschäft
sein haus mit dem gelben balkonen steht
noch drum herum sind ruinen aber er will
so schnell wie möglich wieder eröffnen
nur wenige hundert meter weiter ein
anderes bild eine mondlandschaft die
häuser versunken in der asche jetzt
werden sie schaufel für schaufel
ausgegraben
wir müssen diesen bereich hier
saubermachen anderthalb oder zwei meter
um das haus herum und dann da oben den
tank zu schaffen der besitzer hatte die
gemeinde hat hilfsarbeiter angestellt um
alles schneller zu bewältigen das gebiet
ist erst vor kurzem wieder freigegeben
war hierher zurückgekommen ist noch
keiner der bewohner das geht nicht mit
der ganzen asche es gibt zwar schon
strom aber noch kein wasser es wird wohl
noch monate dauern bis alles weggeräumt
ist auch viele bananenplantagen im
vulkangebiet sind lava und asche zum
opfer gefallen die die verschont blieben
sind in einem desolaten zustand
hallo nach ein paar von indien wird man
noch retten können aber der rest muss
neu gepflanzt werden der vulkan hat
wieder ruhe gegeben aber die zerstörung
die er angerichtet hat wird la palma
noch lange prägen
seine bilder hängen in den weltweit
wichtigsten museen und haben gerhard
richter zu einem der bedeutendsten maler
der gegenwart gemacht und pünktlich zum
neunzigsten geburtstag hat er sich und
seiner geburtsstadt dresden eine
ausstellung geschenkt eine sehr
persönliche schau mit porträts seiner
familie und werken die ihm ganz
besonders wichtig sind steffen moritz
müller
aufmerksamkeit mag er nicht auch nicht
zu seinem neunzigsten geburtstag und so
ist gerhard richter auch nicht zur
eröffnung seiner ausstellung anwesend
nur als selbstbildnis
wochen vorher war er allerdings schon da
in seiner geburtsstadt dresden um die
bilder selbst zu hängen und die räume zu
gestalten
das ist großartig weil es ist eigentlich
dass sein eigenes geburtstagsgeschenk
hat es ganz präzise
vorbereitet und das ist schon in sich
auch sehr radikal und elementar was er
uns hier zeigt gleichzeitig ist es auch
eine brücke von west nach ost und ost
nach west durch die biografie von
gerhard richter
90 jahre wie geber in drei räumen
unmöglich bei dem wohl berühmtesten
maler unserer zeit und so hat er
schwerpunkte gesetzt mit werken die eine
große persönliche bedeutung für ihn
haben in einem raum hat er seine ganze
familie versammelt frau und vier kinder
in öl gemalt
richter wollte nie als maler bezeichnet
werden bildermacher sei der bessere
begriff bilder will er auch mit seinen
glas und spiegel installationen erzeugen
unbegrenzt und mit immer neuen blicken
ein weiterer schwerpunkt seiner
abstrakten werke zu sehen auch das
großformatige sogenannte abstrakte bild
von 2017 womit er sich laut eigener
aussage von den großformaten
verabschiedet hat heute zeichnet er vor
allem aber das so sagt er sei doch
eigentlich nichts besonderes
muss ich mir anschauen noch bis mai
jetzt waren sport und olympia und es
gibt die erste deutsche medaille
christian genau ganz knapp an gold
vorbei und dennoch überglücklich
skispringerinnen katharina althaus hat
trotz der starken konkurrentinnen aus
slowenien und den nicht ganz einfachen
bedingungen die nerven behalten und die
olympische silbermedaille von der
normalschanze gewonnen eine träne
vergoss sie nach ihrem zweiten sprung
und der gerade errungene silbermedaille
katharina althaus völlig überwältigt von
diesem olympischen moment der ersten
deutschen medaille bei diesen
winterspielen irgendwas wobei ich glaube
ich kann mehr halt nichts vorwerfen und
ich bin
als führende ging sie hier in den
zweiten durchgang und sprang 94 metern
gut einen meter weniger als für gold
nötig gewesen wäre das gewann die
slowenin urska bugatti bronze ging an
ihre landsfrau nica krishna
silbermedaillen-gewinnerin althaus
dachte auch an eine mit favoritin die
österreicherin maria kramer die positiv
auf kona getestet wurde natürlich hätte
ich
wäre ich gerne hier mit ihr gesprungen
und hat mich hier mit ihren maßen aber
das macht man dann im weltcup weiterhin
nach diesem ersten edelmetall für
deutschland hat althaus am montag eine
weitere medaille im mixed team
wettbewerb fest im visier
und das erste olympische gold dieser
winterspiele ging an die norwegerin
therese johaug die 33 jährige entschied
den ski adlern für sich vor der russin
dabei war und teresa stadlober aus
österreich beste deutsche katharina
sauerbrei 13
in der ersten biathlon entscheidung auf
gold für norwegen vor frankreich und den
russischen athleten bürger wind bedeutet
einige schießfehler zunächst viel
rückstand für die deutsche mixed-staffel
im laufe des rennens kämpfen sich wann
es erfolgt denise herrmann benedikt doll
und philipp nachfragt dann wieder näher
an die spitze heran schließlich platz
fünf hier muss man ganz ehrlich sagen
hat man gute auftakt erfahrung für die
kommenden einzelrennen aber mehr auch
nicht auf gold-kurs liegt im olympischen
eiskanal nach zwei durchgängen johannes
ludwig zur halbzeit führt der oberhofer
teamkollege felix loch ist vierter
morgen könnten dann deutsche rodel
träume in erfüllung gehen und
eisschnellläuferin claudia pechstein ist
jetzt rekord olympioniken ihr
zwanzigster platz heute für sie
nebensache für mich zählt das ist eben
mit diesen staaten 3000 metern
geschichte geschrieben habe dass ich die
einzige frau auf der ganzen welt bin die
acht mal olympische winterspiele erlebt
und das ist einfach nur ein riesentraum
mit 49 jahren schreibt claudia pechstein
in peking sportgeschichte
und noch zum fußball 21 spieltag der
bundesliga noch ohne ergebnisse des
spitzen trios und bisher ohne erfolge
für die vereine dahinter in augsburg
verliert union berlin 0 2 in köln
unterliegt freiburg 0 1 und hoffenheim 0
2 in mainz stuttgart frankfurt 2 3
bielefeld mönchengladbach eins zu eins
ausführlich zum topspiel bayern münchen
rb leipzig im aktuellen sportstudio
gestern härter bochum eins zu eins
morgen das westduell dortmund leverkusen
und wolfsburg empfängt greuther fürth an
der tabellenspitze kann es noch keine
veränderungen geben dahinter union und
freiburg ohne punktgewinn köln hoch auf
6 hoffenheim runter auf 8 frankfurt
bleibt auf 9 mainz hält anschluss und
führt weiter die untere hälfte an kein
lichtblick für gladbach unverändert auf
12 und nur noch mit zwei punkten abstand
zum relegationsplatz auf dem feld
wolfsburg am ende weiterhin stuttgart
und kräuter führt und mehr natürlich
dazu im sportstudio 23 uhr ja viele ann
christin und dann hätten wir noch dass
eltern werden es kennen man kommt nach
hause und es sieht dann aus wie im
schweinestall so passiert in hagen aber
es macht nicht die kinder sondern ein
wildschwein es kam wohl irgendwie durch
die terrassentür versaute das wohnzimmer
mit samt sofa die herbeigerufene polizei
lockte das gestresste tier dann
vorsichtig zurück nach draußen und das
nennt man dann wohl wirklich schwein
gehabt ja der net nicht beim wetter
leider da erwartet uns ein stürmischer
verregneter sonntag details von katja
ohne vergleich das heute journal um 22
uhr 45 mit bettina schausten von uns war
es das schön abend für sie und wenn sie
mögen gerne bis morgen
[Musik]
guten abend entlang dieses regen bandes
entwickelt sich jetzt gerade eine welle
das ist ein kleines tief und das bringt
morgen besonders dem westen deutschlands
30 bis 50 liter regen pro quadratmeter
in 24 stunden in den mittelgebirgen
fällt auch schnee und es wird sehr
stürmisch schon heute nacht geht das los
mit dem regen im nordwesten und dem
kräftigen wind in den mittelgebirgen ist
schon etwas schnee dabei in der lausitz
aber auch südlich von mosel und main
bleibt es trocken und am alpenrand ist
es sogar klar da sinken die werte bis
minus 8 grad deutlich milder bleibt die
nacht hier in nord statt die
höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen
zwischen 3 und 9 grad und es wird
kräftig regnen oberhalb von 800 metern
fällt auch schnee und im nordwesten sind
gewitter dabei am längsten sonne sehen
sie direkt am alpenrand sie sollten sich
auch sturmböen gefasst machen fast in
ganz deutschland in norddeutschland ist
es etwas ruhiger mal abgesehen von den
küsten es gibt sogar orkanböen in den
gipfellagen von schwarzwald und
schwäbischer alb aber auch am alpenrand
können durchaus windgeschwindigkeiten
über 120 kilometer pro stunde erreicht
werden am montag schneit es noch am
längsten im erzgebirge und am alpenrand
der dienstag wird ruhiger und der
mittwoch mit schönes wochenende